somebody ripped out the article and
Scott Baio no here it is oh he is
[ __ ] hot I'm sorry he's still cute I
mean he was really is
look at that hair that cute little
hairdo really cute you know I'm just
gonna read um he started out in
commercials and news 13 sellout yeah I
mean there's no such a dude there's no
selling out anymore is there it's a
movie star I love is done a commercial
it's a true man yeah it was really
depressing you know is the most
depressing thing was did people see
[ __ ] Bob Dylan do a commercial in the
Super Bowl that was it for me they stole
all the movies you get what you pay for
what the [ __ ] they supposed to do cuz
then if he keeps it real then he [ __ ]
you know has to walk down the street
with all the regular people and then
they're just gonna give him [ __ ] Bob
what happened to you you [ __ ] fell off
right so [ __ ] it put it in a Carl's jr.
commercial have you ever seen a Meryl
Marcos blog about Bob Dylan no she lives
near him in Malibu Mara Marco really
funny writer used to write for Letterman
like he has a string of Christmas lights
that he has outside of his home every
year but year-round just one string but
then at Christmas shuffles it up two
strings
that's so diligent he takes a picture of
it every year and puts it on this blog
called Bob Dylan's Christmas lights so
don't come to sell out yeah I know it's
a big tree up or something then you can
you know to have something to say but I
think I do count like commercial anyway
I went you know I want you to know one
thing about Scott Baio he wishes he
could do Happy Days for 20 years and he
doesn't even know [ __ ] Charles in
Charge is happening that's why no clue
don't wish for things cuz it could get
even better than your own dumb wishes
you know you don't know it's best for
you only the Lord does Lourdes